[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy by nine votes 217 to 208 the
House of Representatives recently voted
down a proposal to identify Islamic
religious doctrines concepts or schools
of thought that jihad terrorists use 20
Republicans joined the solid Democratic
bloc to vote down this measure which
Muslim representative Keith Ellison a
Democrat from Minnesota termed
wrongheaded and fought very hard to
defeat now it's hard to believe that
there would be 217 votes against
understanding the ideology that
motivates and incites jihad violence but
that testifies to the power of the
Islamic obeah victimhood Lobby today the
measure would have directed the Defense
Department to carry out strategic
assessments of the use of violent or
unorthodox Islamic religious doctrine to
support extremists or terrorists
messaging and justification now in
reality there's nothing unorthodox about
Jihad violence an Islamic law and
doctrine yet even though this
specification that the Islamic doctrines
to be studied were indeed unorthodox
allowed for support from those who hold
that Jihad terror is a twisting and
hijacking of the religion of peace that
wasn't good enough according to Politico
the proposal drew heavy criticism from
Muslim lawmakers serving in Congress
Muslim interest groups and the American
Civil Liberties Union who say the
proposal would unfairly target Muslims
Ellison added if you have an amendment
that says we're going to study one
religion and only one we're going to
look at their leaders and put them on a
list only them and you're going to talk
about what's Orthodox practice and
what's unorthodox then you are putting
extra scrutiny on that religion well
yeah and there's reason for that 30,000
jihad attacks committed in the name of
Islam and in accord with its teachings
since September 11th 2001
no one religion has anything approaching
that kind of record of death and
destruction
except Islam so why shouldn't we put
extra scrutiny on Islam Ellison who took
thirteen thousand three hundred fifty
dollars from the Muslim Brotherhood
organization known as the Muslim
American Society to finance his
pilgrimage to Mecca also claimed that
the measure was abridging the free
exercise of that religion well yeah
once again insofar as the free exercise
of Islam involves bombs ak-47s machetes
and so on yeah it needs to be restricted
the free exercise of any religion is not
a license to break other laws the free
exercise of any religion is not a free
pass to commit treason or subversion or
sedition the constitutional guarantee of
the free exercise of a religion does not
allow the adherence of that religion to
commit violence in its name and in
accord with its teachings when they
crafted the first amendment the founding
fathers did not envision a religion that
mandated warfare against and the
subjugation of unbelievers nor did they
intend to lace the Constitution or Bill
of Rights with time bombs that would
ultimately destroy the Republic they
were trying to create Nord is studying
the motivating ideology of jihad
terrorists restrict the practice of
Islam by peaceful Muslims in any way and
if these peaceful Muslims are as
appalled by jihad terrorism as Islamic
groups in the u.s. professed to be why
wouldn't they welcome an attempt to
address this alleged misuse of their
religion and support this proposal the
sponsor of the measure representative
Trent Franks Republican from Arizona
noted correctly right now there is a
certain spectrum within the Islamist
world that is at the root of the
ideological impulse for terrorism he
appealed to Muslim moderates he said
ironically moderate Muslims are the
prime targets of these groups to suggest
that this is anti-muslim is a fallacy
and I think that anyone who really
understands it knows that we've worked
very hard to protect the religious
freedom for everybody but it is
important
that we empower American to America to
identify those heroic Muslims within the
world that will help us begin to
delegitimize this ideology of global
jihad his appeal to Muslims of good
faith was of no avail Ellison would not
number himself among the heroic Muslims
who would help us begin to delegitimize
this ideology of global jihad he said of
Frank's and his measure this is the
wrong way to do what he's trying to do
he didn't offer any specifics about what
the right way might be with Allison
leading the way
two hundred and seventeen members of the
House of Representatives including 20
Republicans chose denial and willful
ignorance instead of knowledge of the
beliefs motives and goals of the jihadis
who have vowed to destroy us that's just
asking to be defeated
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]